hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in book two of his work on anger Seneca
is going to consider a number of
objections that people in his own time
were bringing forward and I think that
we see people even up to the present
getting taken in by these are lines of
reasoning about anger that on the
surface seem kind of plausible but are
actually as Seneca is going to point out
quite mistaken and they have to do with
what we can translate as nobility
there's this term that's being used
which is not an obili toss but again
actually it's being used as an adjective
in this genarossus you know again a
Rossi and it does have the sense of
nobility it comes from the word for you
know one's birth meaning the family that
one is Born Into and the idea here is
that there's a kind of you know
aristocratic status to anger and I think
that we do see this a lot not just in
Roman society not just in ancient Greek
society or through the Mediterranean in
the Middle East in general but in many
many other places as well you could say
that this is almost like a Timeless
problem
in many different cultures and so
there's going to be three main
objections that he is considering in
book two in particular in chapters uh 15
and 6 team
one of them in an entire chapter by
itself so let's look at the first one he
talks about the free peoples and as the
examples of these you know typical sort
of Roman and Greek stuff we've got the
Germans and we've got the scythians if
you don't know who the scythians are
they were people who lived north of the
Black Sea uh in you know the the area
that was can you know rather unpopulated
and grassland and they rode horses and
they fought and every once in a while
they'd come down and raise some hell
among the more you know civilized
peoples to the South and they were
viewed as being very brave being very
tough right the Germans of course lots
of different tribes of them the Romans
had to fight against them a number of
times along with their their various
allies you know so it could be Romans
and Gauls against Germans and Seneca
says people will say that these people
people are most disposed to anger
iraqundisi Mai right and I think it's
important to pause there on that term
because Seneca earlier on in book one
talks about irukundiya as being the
disposition right the you could call it
motivational structure or habit that
disposes a person to get angry much more
easily to not be in control of their
anger so he's saying that a lot of
people will point out that there's
entire societies entire races of people
who are like that and Seneca says all
right yeah there's there's something to
this this happens because naturally
brave people who have uh a nature a
Natura and uh it's sort of part of who
they are in Genia people who have a
brave nature and a substantial nature so
ludicue are going to be prone to anger
if something doesn't happen it doesn't
mean that they're naturally going to
just be angry all the time it's when
they're untrained or as he's going to
say a little bit later
unshaped we human beings have the
possibility of Education of discipline
of formation of taking what it is that
we're born with or have by virtue of our
families and culture and reworking that
in a deliberate way and that's what's
not happening he thinks among the
so-called free peoples he does also buy
a little bit into what we can call a
prevalent Goldilocks theory that the
Greeks and Romans uh rather
self-servingly endorsed where you have
you know people who live in the North
because of that the irascible part of
themselves is over developed they're
dealing with the cold and you know wild
animal goals and living in in difficult
circumstances and that's the too much
right and then in the South with like
the Egyptians and the syrians and the
Persians ah to to weak not angry enough
not uh you know not riled up about
things too easy to rule and then in the
middle you know again rather
self-servingly the Romans the Greeks the
people who are born to actually exercise
rule because they have the right sort of
composition now you know is there
anything to this geographical or racial
determinism probably not but he is going
to bring this up uh as as one of the
explanations and then he says coming
back to this training
certain traits are inborn only in better
Natures like sturdy and prolific stands
of trees that the Earth Bears however
uncultivated a forest grows tall and
fertile soil right and so he talks about
naturally Gallant characters a gallant
meaning just you know Brave right uh are
wrathful they they're hot fiery in
nature contains nothing slight and
delicate but it needs to be on it needs
to be shaped and formed right uh all the
traits that arise only from the good of
nature itself without skills guidance
can go bad and so without this training
there's shaping bravery or courage
fortitude this virtue this very good
trait uh is going to go bad and turn
into recklessness and rashness and
anybody who's you know read the nick of
McCain ethics recognizes this as sort of
the vice that is opposed to the virtue
of Courage by having too much too much
confidence not enough actual fear or
Prudence right so that's what's going to
happen to these naturally or culturally
angry people and he throws in one other
thing that's actually quite interesting
here
one consideration they're unable to rule
is how it's translated but we might
translate this as
organize and Rule effectively right
imperative they're they're unable to
have lasting power structures because
they jockey for position with each other
they get too angry they fight with each
other and he says that they're unable to
command why because although they're not
slavish they're also too as he says
Fierce fairy right wild is another way
of Translating that and intractable
which is just a transliteration of
interact abilities right unable to be
molded to be shaped to work with and he
says that um
uh
no one is able to rule who cannot also
be ruled they resist that so they're not
able to rule effectively again something
that comes from Aristotle discussed in
the politics right then he goes on to
talk about animals so we're going to
leave behind examples of the tough guy
cultures that people love to talk about
and imitate and pretend to be and we
might even think about you know our own
time and what this might apply to people
wanting to do the Maori Haka right it's
kind of silliness right unless you when
unless you understand it in its cultural
context you know taking that on and
pretending you're a tough guy pretending
to be one of the free peoples probably
not a good thing for you from seneca's
perspective we could say so so much
about others as well those who worship
the military and soldiers because they
watch commercials about Marines doing
crazy things on TV that they don't
actually do in in real Combat so there's
this cultural thing and then we can talk
about animals this is also a cultural
thing right animals don't generally look
at other animals and say oh man I should
be like that I'm a snake but I should be
like a bird or I'm a raven and I should
be like that deer over there no we human
beings are the ones who to some degree
anthropomorphize animals and then say
let's be like that think about how many
people you know he's going to bring up
Lions think about how many people love
to use the image of a lion even for by
the way stoicism where the lion is not a
good thing right they'll put it on their
book they'll put it on their website
they'll put it in their coaching program
you're like what's wrong with you don't
you understand that the lion is not
actually in this respect a good creature
certainly not in terms of anger
but you know there's a lot of people out
there who say animals that possess a lot
of anger literally in in whom there's a
lot of anger are considered the most
noble gerosima right and so who does he
talk about well lions and wolves and
other sorts of beasts of prey right and
the stoic you know attitude towards that
is those aren't the models to actually
imitate
um
there's a couple different reasons for
that the first is
you're not a lion you're not a wolf
you're not any of those things you're a
human being you shouldn't be imitating
the example the bad example of
particular animals right just because
they seem cool or something and he says
um you know if you're going to imitate
animals why wouldn't you imitate better
ones or instead you know when you have
the universe and God whom a human being
alone of all animals comprehends you can
imitate God
don't imitate some brute beast and say
oh I'm cool I'm great I'm brave because
I'm like the lion you know or the jaguar
or pick whatever other animal you
crocodile you know that you want to and
then he also points out listen
not all the animals are served by being
you know the tough guys of the animal
kingdom as a matter of fact a lot of
them are served by other things he
brings up the deer who is served by you
know fear and and flight right
um
who else does he have uh you know attack
AIDS the Hawk flight the dove right so
that's important to keep in mind and
then he asks a very funny question so if
you actually buy into this line of
reasoning are you saying that the more
Angry a predator is the more generous
the more noble the better an animal it
is an animal of its own kind I mean
think about this just for a second a
lion that cannot get along with other
Lions because it's always getting angry
is going to get kicked out of the pack
even if it's a really tough lion right
it's not going to rule forever it's
going to get older and then the other
male lions or the female lions are going
to Maul the crap out of it and send it
packing right then we can say the same
thing about others there's sort of a
healthy amount for that kind of animal
of anger or drive or whatever it is
Seneca actually doesn't consider that
anger anyway
and then there's a going Beyond even for
animals
the last one that he brings up is
another thing that we often see well at
least the angry people you know where
you stand with them right they don't be
us around they don't conceal they tell
you what they think a lot of people see
that as a good thing obviously until
it's turned against them right and so he
says wrathful people are considered the
most straightforward of all people now
straightforward is Simplicity me right
the simple the it's above board you know
exactly what you're getting and Seneca
says well sure but not per se but rather
by comparison to the deceitful and the
tricky people right they appear
straightforward because they act without
concealment and the reason they act
without concealment is because they
can't even manage to conceal or rein in
their passion of anger
and he says should we really describe
them as straightforward or is there a
better term that we could use here and
he says they're actually incautious they
don't think before they speak they jump
into situations without assessing the
dangers involved because they're angry
and they want to fight right and he says
that this is the name in cautious is the
name that we give to foolishness luxury
wastefulness and all the devices
deficient in cleverness right so there's
a positive spin that's often given to
anger by a lot of people and Seneca is
trying to attack that straight on and
say
people who you know buy their
constitution or their culture or their
individual upbringing are prone to anger
especially prone to anger and not
because of that more noble or generous
or magnanimous or whatever you want to
say we shouldn't be imitating animals
just because we think that they're cool
and they Inspire us and angry people are
not straightforward in the good sense of
the term but rather just saying their
mind without really thinking it through
or acting on it in many cases as well so
these are some important objections that
we see not only in his time but in our
own time and cultures and Seneca has
some really good answers for these